[Music]
welcome back to Hannity so earlier today
the first daughter and advisor to the
president of Anka Trump she hosted a
town hall on tax reform in Pennsylvania
we need money back i sat down with
Ivanka Trump to discuss how the
administration plans to move the tax
proposal forward and pass it take a look
by joining us now Ivanka Trump good to
see you how are you walk in the door you
start making fun of me I mean this is a
great way to start an interview you know
somebody's got to do it somebody's got
to do it you have an assistant yes or
somebody that works for you in PR mhm
and I did something go ahead you can
tell everybody it's fine you tried to
set her up and and we're almost
successful but what really excited me
about this story is when I found out
that you actually had a website where
you were making matches because this is
Jared and my secret Talent people don't
realize it's our it's our hidden skill
we're matchmakers do you like to put
people together seven marriages zero
divorces oh my god willing that
continues but seven matches so I was
feeling really good about myself I was
excited to tell you that statistic and
then found out that you literally have
hundreds I have like babies are being
born and I don't know why I used to do
these long book signings that were gonna
go on for hours and when there was a
cute couple come up I'm like oh how long
you been dating they'd say three years
and I said what are you waiting for
and the next thing the girlfriends
always going yes and the guy's going
like this and I say do it right now and
I get the crowd to say and a lot of guys
would do it so oh my gosh you and Jerry
Jared's always pushing people he's like
you have all the facts you have all the
facts that you need to know yeah make
the move make the moves yeah but a lot
of people appreciate it and they did get
married I even have a child named after
me which and dogs I have more dogs than
children all right so it's almost a year
since your dad won and you've gotten
involved in a lot of issues but what
you're really focused in now is what I
think this election was about and that
is the Forgotten men and women and
that's why this tax reform bill it's
probably his biggest and most important
piece of legislation to bring about the
economic success
he was running on look I feel a so
privileged to have the opportunity to
serve our country and you know nothing
about my life was designed to pick up
and move to Washington but I feel really
blessed that he entrusted in me and
empowered me to do this but you know
ultimately it's about the amazing people
of this country that I met over two
years of campaigning and the hardships I
witnessed the opportunity to remove
barriers so that more people can
experience some of the privileges that
my family and I were we're so lucky to
have so you know this country gave us
everything it afforded us so many
incredible opportunities and and my
mission now if your job creation through
economic growth is to empower as many
Americans as I possibly can to realize
those same opportunities this
administration is doing it we're doing
it legislatively tax reform is so
critical we're doing it administrative
Lee deregulation really fueling
entrepreneurship in this country and you
see it in terms of optimism you see it
in terms of the stock market you see it
in terms of the conversations you have
I'm here today in Bucks County
Pennsylvania and I would hear it in
every conversation I had with with the
people through the course of the day and
and in the room so that's what that's
what fuels us and that's what we're
fighting for you did a very good job of
getting rid of burdensome regulations
something as a conservative I talk about
all the time because it puts so much
pressure on businesses they can't just
go out and do their job they have to
work with the EPA then they have to work
with this other agency and not that we
shouldn't take care of the environment
of course we've got to be good stewards
of the environment
some good regulation but it's gotten out
of control and things that somebody in
Washington thought in principle was a
good idea would have unintended
consequences to millions of people so
there's a lot of bad regulation that
didn't fulfill the stated goal even if
the intent was pure so I think rolling
back years decades of layer upon layer
of regulation is really freeing up
business owners to invest in their
businesses invest in the people who work
in their businesses you see wage growth
for the first time and I think tax
reform you know is so core to our goal
of fueling the economic growth of this
country we need to be competitive we
need a tax code that's reflective of the
modern reality of what our workforce
look like including supporting our
working families the majority of which
are now dual income which is why I'm
really excited about the realization of
a large part of the administration's
working family agenda through tax reform
the expansion of the child tax credit
doubling the standard deduction
eliminating the marriage penalty there's
so many critical elements that support
our dual values of work and a family but
we need to be competitive and ultimately
we need growth and that's going to come
by ensuring that this is the country
that everyone wants to grow their
business is amazing you dad
rightly said yeah we have 1% GDP growth
that's worth two point five trillion
dollars to the Treasury that's that's a
lot of money and the last administration
was the first one ever to reach 3% GDP
growth isn't here I want to go back to
the issue you brought up you've been
privileged because I feel the same way
in this sense I grew up in very middle
class in America
dishwasher at 12 busboy waiter bartender
house painter wallpaper hanger tile
there framer roofer I did it all he's
about to amazing
it's a pretty good list but so I look at
the economic plan and I'm like okay we
get the factories and manufacturing
centers built here because corporations
have lower taxes because we have less
regulation it's a better environment the
repatriation of trillions from
multinationals that would not bring it
back here because they'll lose 40 or 50
cents on every dollar and you make it 10
cents
they're gonna spend a lot of money here
and that's a bipartisan issue
everyone's been talking for years about
all this money that's parked off our
shores that wants to come back into this
country and nobody's ever been able to
do anything about it so this tax plan
fixes that and enables businesses to
bring the money home to invest in the
their infrastructure their businesses
right here and invest in their workers
but but to your point about being
competitive the reality is it's a global
global marketplace now and we have to
compete against other countries and we
are not competitive we have the highest
corporate tax of any country in the
developed world and that is something
that very much gets factored into our
pricing very much gets factored into
wages that's why they've stagnated over
the past several decades and you just
now are starting to see them rise and I
think a big part of that is the
deregulation we were talking about
before but I believe with my heart and
soul and my father does and this
administration does that no one can best
the American worker there is no group of
people more innovative more motivated
more capable but there's got to be a
level playing field and there's not a
level playing field that is we've got a
level the playing fields for the
corporation the small business who's
spending 60 billion dollars a year to
comply with a cumbersome tax code
to the individual I mean the reality is
simplification of our tax code
democratizes it it does you know if you
have a tax code that the average person
can't understand I know I can't you know
94% of Americans require professional
help to fill out their taxes whose
that's going to benefit it's going to
benefit the person with an army of
accountants and an army of lawyers who
can help them find the loopholes and the
nuance
okay you can give the same factual
information 2/3 of the best accounting
houses in America yeah and they'll come
up with a different tax liability yeah I
mean that's how complicated it and
they're not cheating they just another
second so those decades of lobbyists and
special interest group who added a
nuance here and nuance there a page here
an idea here and part of the promise of
this tax reform is cutting all of that
out simplifying it democratizing it and
making it work for all Americans with a
particular focus on middle income
America and that is so important and you
know and and what we're all fighting for